Okay, so I'm going to be talking about
domain-specific agents and why I really
think that they are going to play an
unbelievably important role in the
future of AI and in the future of how we
build agents.
To get started real quick, my name's
Justin Schrader. Uh you can find me on X
at JP Schrader. And um I work at a small
company called Standard Agents, which
nobody's heard of right now cuz we're
still kind of in stealth mode. Um after
this talk, if you're interested, feel
free to reach out to me and uh I can let
you know a little bit more.
Mostly, I'm known for doing a lot of
different open-source projects. Uh Dmux,
which is a great multiplexer for all of
your coding agents.
Uh ArrowJS, which is sort of like a UI
framework, sort of like React for um the
agentic era. A bunch more that I won't
get into, but you know, maybe check them
out if you're interested.
Okay.
I think we can all agree that the moment
in time that we are in is very similar
to the Industrial Revolution. Um in
fact, it might be like an accelerated
Industrial Revolution. Maybe it's a
bigger deal, but it's certainly not
smaller. I probably don't need to
convince you of that if you're listening
to one of these talks. Um but that is
the moment we find us find ourselves in.
So, I actually think it's helpful to go
back and sort of look at what was the
key catalyst of the Industrial
Revolution. And ultimately, it was that
we learned how to harness energy with
machines.
We learned how to harness energy with
machines. And what's interesting is that
in this next era, we are essentially
learning to harness intelligence with
agents.
And agents, I think, can be thought of a
little bit like the machine of
yesteryear. It's the thing that is going
to use the intelligence. Not so much us,
but the agents.
What's interesting about that is I bet
if I was in an actual room with you guys
and and we all put up our hands, I bet a
lot of you when I say what is an agent
instantly have examples that pop into
mind, but also probably can't pull out a
definition immediately. Some of you
maybe can,
um but the reality is that we haven't
even coalesced on a definition
of what an agent is, even though we're
well into the agentic era at this point.
And I think that's kind of interesting.
Um here's my definition. You can feel
free to agree with it or not, but agents
are deterministic software that harness
the non-deterministic results produced
by models in pursuit of some desired
objective.
Now,
deterministic software might make you
think more like a harness, and I
actually think the distinction between
an agent and a harness is really
pedantic, not very helpful, um and for
the most part, in most cases, you can
just conflate the two. A harness is an
agent and an agent is a harness, okay?
And for the for the purposes of this
talk, we're going to go ahead and just
move forward with that. I think you
could probably make some good arguments
for why one is the other and vice versa,
but really not important right now.
Now, if you did have some examples pop
to mind, they might have been like
Claude or Codex,
um you know, OpenClaude, Hermes. But you
know what's interesting is I bet if you
went out onto, you know, the the streets
of corporate America in any city, maybe
not San Francisco, but any city in
America, and you asked somebody just in
an office building, could you name an
agent
by name?
I think some people are going to get
Claude.
Some people might get Codex.
And that's about it. I don't think
hardly anybody's going to be getting
OpenClaude or Hermes. Uh Uh, and and
really even Claude, I don't know that
people would even know that that's an
agent.
These things are not well understood.
And yet, what's so crazy is everybody is
building agents. I have a real estate
agency down the street that's building
agents. I know in like independent
private insurance brokers building their
own agents. I know Fortune 500
companies, lots of them, building their
own custom agents. Everybody is trying
to build their own custom agents. And I
know people don't believe me, uh, but go
talk to them. Just go talk to people.
They are trying to build custom agents.
And I can't help but wonder why. Nobody
seems to be asking this question, why?
There's already AI everywhere. You can
get on ChatGPT all the way down to some
open-source model from China on some,
you know, rickety website. There's
everything in between, but still people
want to build custom agents. And
ultimately, it comes down to
integration. Businesses want their data
properly integrated into AI. They They
believe, and are probably right, that if
they appropriately leverage AI, they're
going to have these dramatic gains in
their business and so on and so forth.
So, they need to figure out how to get
integrated. And building their own
custom agents is obviously a way to do
that. And it's one of the first ways
that they discover, um, as a mechanism
for doing it. The problem, though, is
that agents are really hard. You have to
take very, very careful care of the
agentic loop and make sure that it's
properly orchestrated. There are a ton
of different provider abstractions you
need to think about. Um, fortunately,
there's some good tools coming out
around that, you know, like the
the Vercel AI SDK is great. Um,
durable execution, you need to make sure
if there's faults, we can pick back up.
These are relatively hard problems, um,
especially if you're thinking about it
at scale.
And the reality is there's just tons
more. There's all kinds of validations
and stop conditions and so on and so
forth.
And so what often happens is people do
try to build their own custom agents,
and they sort of work as a demo, but but
not much more than that. Um, and really
it turns out that it's an absolute
nightmare for people. Um, building
robust agents is just hard. And if you
go talk to anybody in an IT department,
they are pulling their hair out because
there are so many different concerns.
Um, there's no defined way to build an
agent right now. Like, actually no
defined way. The closest thing maybe is,
uh, Eve that just came out from Vercel
is maybe like the closest thing. Um, but
in reality, everybody's kind of coming
up with their own way to do it.
Um, telemetry and observability on these
agents is unbelievably hard, especially
at scale. Like, if you want to know
exactly what is getting transmitted on
every single step of every single turn
of your agent, so that way you can
diagnose it and fine-tune it and make
sure things aren't going off the rails,
that is very hard to do.
Uh, agents are also not portable. So, if
I do get a good agent working, if I've
managed to climb to the top of, you
know, this mountain and I've got a good
agent that's finally working well, well,
it works well on my machine.
>> [laughter]
>> But if I try to pass it off to somebody
else, there's a very high likelihood
that between all of the environment
variable configurations and and system
requirements and and runtimes, there's a
good chance it's not going to run on
that person's machine.
And they're not composable. So, even if
I get, you know, a really good chatbot
working for my university, the chances
that I'm going to then be able to reuse
that for another thing is very, very
low. I can't just easily share that.
So, what often happens is after a short
pursuit towards agents, people kind of
back away and say, "Okay, fine. No more
agents, no agents. Instead, we're going
to do the MCP thing. We've heard about
this, it works." And sure enough,
Model Context Protocol, it does work.
And really, it it works pretty well to
take, you know, your corporate
information like Zillow's information
and then shove that into one of these
really large
pre-existing agents, something like
Claude or ChatGPT, which I would
consider a large general-purpose agent.
Um and it and it sort of works like
that. Uh
and and it works okay. But if you take a
look, this is actually from the MCP
website, and if you take a look at what
is supported in MCP clients around the
world, you will notice that only one of
these columns is actually filled out all
the way down.
And that, of course, is tools.
So, MCP has become a de facto tool
distribution mechanism for agents. So,
if I need to get my company's tools into
that other agent, then MCP's a good way
to do that. It has not proven to be
great at providing other value yet.
And frankly, tools are just not enough.
You know, I I I
I like to joke that we didn't land a man
on the moon by giving one guy a ton of
tools.
That's not a realistic way to get a
really large project done.
So, uh you know, maybe MCP's not the
way, but aha, we have skills. We have
skills, and skills are great. Um I I I
actually do enjoy skills. I'm sure you
do, too. We install them all the time
for all kinds of things. And
fundamentally, what a skill is is a
markdown file, which basically works as
documentation.
Now, interestingly, there's lots of
research out there that shows that if
you use very many of these, it actually
makes your agent substantially worse.
But, they do work as documentation for
various complex things.
So, you know, back to the analogy of a
man getting to the moon, it's a little
bit like just giving this guy, you know,
a ton of documentation. And the
documentation's going to help, but it's
not the fundamental problem.
So, what's the fundamental problem?
Okay.
Let's build up a basic agent stack here.
Let's start with a model. All agents
start with a model.
Big one, small one, doesn't matter. They
Then, you have something like a system
prompt on top of that, which tells the
model what its role in the grand
universe is, sort of like its its life
objective.
Then, we have tools, the things that it
can actually do, the effects it can
take.
And then, skills would be layered on top
of that. And then, MCP would be layered
on top of that. And then, finally, you
have all the messages from the
conversation. That is roughly the stack
of information that gets passed along
within the runtime of an agent.
And if you take a look here, almost all
of it
is context.
Basically, everything. The system
prompt, tools, skills, all of that is
stuff that ends up in the context of the
agent.
And so, basically, people are trying to
solve the integration problem by working
on the context or the model. These are
the two areas where we constantly see
new advances. We also see, you know, new
new things come out like skills and and
MCP, um new technologies, new protocols.
They are all coming out in the in the
area of the context and the model.
So, how does it actually work then?
Well, basically, you work at a company,
you occasionally need to do some
business travel, so you've got a couple
travel
MCPs installed. You've also got, you
know, Figma and Playwright installed on
yours. And all of these are building up
in that context layer. And then you've
got some, you know, Gmail MCPs to go
check your mail for you and some Google
Sheets to go fill out some other uh some
other uh expense reports or something
like that. And then you've got skills.
You're a developer, so you've got some
React fixers and linters. This is
actually, I think, like, the number one
or the number two most popular MCP
server that's out there.
Um maybe you've got uh Matt's uh grill
me skill or or maybe you've got the
GitHub skill.
And basically, what you're doing is you
are inflating that context layer. And we
have a term for this in engineering.
It's called inheritance. The idea of
inheritance is you take an object and
then you add more attributes to it to
allow that one object to have other
properties.
Right? And that's exactly what we are
doing here with an agent. We're saying,
"This agent is pretty good, but if we
add all of these addish- additional
extra layers, then the agent can do
stuff that it previously couldn't do
before." That is exactly what
inheritance is. And the truth about
inheritance is it works. It does work.
That's why these things are out there
and they are working.
But, there's an old saying,
"Composition over inheritance." And it
turns out this this is as old as time.
Eventually, inheritance starts to break
down. Imagine, like, you know, okay,
I've got five skills on uh ChatGPT or on
or on Claude, excuse me. And uh that
works pretty well. Now, what if I have
100 skills? What if I have 1,000 skills?
There's some point at which I get
diminishing returns from adding
additional context. That's That's just
obvious. We all kind of understand that
implicitly.
So, is there an alternative?
Well, composition is the alternative to
inheritance. It looks something like
this. So, like imagine we have another
little agent, and again, we're trying to
provide Figma as an as a as a thing that
can be done by our primary agent. Well,
what we could do is have a tiny little
agent where the actual system prompt of
the agent is written specifically to be
a Figma agent. It knows everything about
Figma. It it knows all of its all of its
context, all of its API, all of the
right places to click and the things to
do and mouse movements to make and
everything like that. And then it has
these precise tools that it needs to
perform all of those actions, and
nothing more. Just that.
And then a very small message history,
which just has to do with the Figma
portion of this. And then you can have
more of these. You can still have your
Gmail and your travel and your Google
Sheets and all that kind of stuff, but
each of them is a separate isolated
agent, a full agent.
Not just a little server with tools on
it. It's a full agent with its own
message history, its own agentic loop.
And then above these, you have a
coordinator.
And the communication mechanism for all
of these small agents speaking to the
larger agent above it is just English.
They just talk to each other the way a
human does.
So, if the primary agent is saying, "Oh,
I should I should check my mail to see
if there's anything about going on a
trip." Well, it knows to go ask Gmail
for any new uh emails about a trip.
Those funnel their way back up, says,
"Oh, yeah, actually there's a trip
coming up to Los Angeles this weekend."
And then it can go to our travel agent
and start to make bookings.
That's kind of a a rough idea of how
something like this could work.
And the reality is it does work. And we
know it works because this is actually
how we got to the moon.
There were teams of experts. Teams of
experts with faces that looked like that
and faces that looked like that. Each of
them with different skills and
capabilities.
And faces that looked like that. This is
the Apollo 11 launch day. And look right
here, there's an agent. I just found an
agent sitting right there.
>> [laughter]
>> That brain of his is that's his LLM. And
here's his tools right there on the
dashboard. Those are the tools. Now, he
didn't have all the tools. He just had
those tools. And he was really really
really good at them.
And then look at that mouth. That's the
messages.
Uh we are used to this. We can
understand this. It implicitly works.
It's almost a form of biomimicry for the
agentic world. Um it works.
And I call them domain-specific agents.
Um I don't think I was the first person
to utter the words domain-specific
agents. Certainly not the first person
to have this idea.
Um but that is what I want to talk to
you about. Agents that are just targeted
to very specific domain.
And we over here at Standard Agents have
been building this ecosystem for quite
some time. So we've gotten to have a
really good inside look at how they
actually work. And I'm not ready to come
out here and announce a product or
anything like that. Um but I can give
you a little bit of a peek. First of
all, they are far more token efficient.
Far more token efficient. We regularly
see over 80% token efficiency for any
given task.
Now, it's a little more complicated
because you have to define those tasks a
little bit more ahead of time.
But if you can have an agent portability
where I can take that Gmail agent,
squeeze it up, and then send it to
somebody else, we can create an
ecosystem where we don't have to create
every one of these skills and
capabilities, but within that domain,
you're going to get dramatic efficiency.
Um and part of the reason is, if you
think about the way that the context
work works, I don't need to have the
entire context of the conversation when
I make a choice to do something.
Instead, my primary coordinator level
can just ask the Gmail uh hey, get that
last email from Debbie. And that is the
totality of the context. It literally
just has the system message, its tools,
and that message that came in. And so,
it is then able to perform this very
targeted, very specialized, tiny little
thing
without all of the surrounding context.
It's also
far more practical with small language
models.
If you look at the difference in two
models like DeepSeek uh
V4 Flash and uh Fable 5,
the cost difference is mind-boggling. It
is 137
times cheaper than Fable per task.
and 37 times.
Now, granted, if
DeepSeek V4 Flash fails over and over
and over again to do the job, then not
only is it going to be, you know, not
that much cheaper, it's also going to be
much more annoying to use it. But that's
why domain-specific agents are so great,
because you don't need to have the V4
Flash do everything.
Instead, it only needs to do the tasks
that have been specifically picked for
it to do. And with a very minimal
context, it can execute those very
faithfully.
So, you get these dramatic cost
reductions not only with the token
efficiency, but also because you can use
much smaller language models and even
non-language models. You can use image
generation and diffusion models. You can
use all kinds of other models for
smaller tasks.
>> [snorts]
>> You can also enforce really strict
limits on the capabilities. And I think
you know what I'm talking about. I'm
talking about this. Uh we are all flying
awfully close to the sun nowadays.
We're everybody's just bypassing
permissions left and right. And of
course, you have to because
a coding agent with a big model can do
anything.
And so, we use it to do everything.
In a world that would be powered by
smaller domain-specific agents, those
agents can't do everything. They can
only do the things that are already
explicitly approved for them to do. It
doesn't mean that you still can't have
permissions and permission dialogues,
but you are opting into a much more
controlled ecosystem. And I promise you,
when you explain that to
Doug in IT, he puts his heart at ease
understanding the difference between
those two.
>> [snorts]
>> And uh fourth, they these have excellent
scaling characteristics. Because each of
these agents is its own small little
execution environment, you can
parallelize them. You can put them on
the cloud very easily without needing
like a giant VPC up there. You can run
thousands of instances all at the same
time um in in all kinds of regions of
the world. They don't actually need to
be uh you know, geographically
co-located or anything like that. Um so,
they have very, very good scaling
characteristics.
Unfortunately, they don't exist.
That's the downside.
>> [laughter]
>> These domain-specific agents don't
really exist.
Um not in a big public way.
Like I said, here at Standard Agents, we
have them. We are working with them on a
daily basis,
but they are not out there in public
very much yet.
However, that's changing. That is going
to change very quickly. We're about
halfway through 2026,
and and I'm here to make a public
prediction that I think as we roll on
from from this point to the end of 2026,
we are going to see a dramatic uptick in
people talking about building
domain-specific agents, frameworks
around them. All kinds of things are
coming down the pipe. And it's not going
to be a small trickle. It's it's going
to accelerate rapidly, and this will
become a one of the main players in the
agentic ecosystem. And 2027, I would
say, is basically the year of
multi-agent orchestration. That's
another word you'll start to hear a lot,
I think.
So, that's my big bold public
prediction. I was really excited just a
few days ago when Vercel released Eve.
This is the first time I actually saw
the term that I had been blasting out
into the void
come back and hit me in my own face.
The framework for building agents build
a company brain, personal assistant, or
domain-specific
agent. So, there we go. About halfway
through the year,
we're going to start picking up steam.
That's my prediction.
And there's a number of reasons. One of
them is
something that most people believe right
now is that the cost of intelligence is
going down. That trend reversed in 2026,
actually. We track this on on a website.
Tokens are not getting cheaper anymore.
They are actually going up even when
adjusted for IQ. They're up 29% when you
adjust for IQ just this year, halfway
through the year, we're already up 30%
and that can be caused by lots of
different things. Of course, um we've
got this memory crunch and and you know,
probably the long-term trend over a
10-year cycle or something is that
intelligence will go down, but that does
not mean that we need to be paying 137
times the cost for something that can be
done just as effectively. The problem is
it's harder to break those things apart.
Now, if you don't account for IQ,
tokens are up 76%
this year, almost 100% increase in
tokens just this year.
Um and we're we're not even halfway
through it. So,
we are really trending upwards on on
token costs. So, anything we can do,
especially with large businesses, to
bring that down is going to be really
important. Um the other the other use
case to really consider is putting AI in
front of customers. You can't put Fable
in front of a customer,
um unless that customer has a massive
lifetime value. It's just too expensive.
So, you need to find a way to create
great efficacy while being efficient.
And domain-specific agents are going to
be the way to do that. So, I'm going to
leave you here in momentarily, um but
before I do, let's just dream a little
bit. Let me dig in a little bit deeper
to how an agent could be orchestrated
and what an ideal agent would actually
look like. And then, I promise to leave
you alone.
Here we go. So, remember we got that
model and we got the system prompt. And
then, at the tool layer, let's break
that apart a little bit. On one hand, we
have these like functions. This would be
like an actual function that can get
executed, like write a file to the file
system.
Then, we have prompts.
Prompts are a lot like the system
prompt, but they are smaller individual
prompts that can get injected
and and sub prompts that can you know,
you can run a function that actually
calls an LLM. So, let's say I have a
main agent running, but I want to use
Nano Banana just to generate an image
when I'm using GLM you know, 5.2 as my
primary. Well, you can just have a tool
that's a prompt. That would be really
cool if you could do that.
And then another type of tool could be
another full-blown agent, like a
complete other domain specific agent
could just be one of the tools.
So, that's the tool layer.
And then you have hooks.
Uh what are hooks? Well, in this
ideal world, a hook might be something
that can kind of harness or change or
mutate or perform side effects. So, let
me give you an example. LLMs have no
idea what time it is at any given point
in time. Turns out a really great way to
tell them what time it is is you inject
an artificial message or an artificial
tool call in the message history. So,
[snorts] it looks like somebody just
said, "Hey, what time it is?" and the
other person replied, "Oh, it's 6:45
p.m. Pacific time."
Pretty simple.
Um you can do that with a hook. Or you
could fire off some side effect using a
hook. So, this is an important piece of
an agent.
And then finally, there's there's these
agent rules. And agent rules are kind of
complicated. It's like how many times
should one side have a turn? Like can it
go on for 10,000 turns uh or 10,000
steps before it's turn is up? You know,
there's there's all kinds of interesting
little rules. You know, when it calls uh
a tool, you know, is it required to
validate the whole thing or not, you
know? All kinds of of very specific
tools uh or or rules that that belong to
a specific agent. And altogether, if we
bundle all that up, we would call that
an agent. But, it's kind of missing a
couple things. One,
every agent should really have a file
system. If you've ever done this with
ChatGPT or Claude or Codex, if you just
ask it, you know, not inside of a
project or anything like, "Hey, can you
make me
a PDF for my my son's birthday party?"
Well, it'll do it. And it'll store it in
its own little file system. So, the big
labs have already realized that in order
to create an effective chat interface,
not to mention a big agent, it needs
some sort of file system. So, every
agent should have its own little sandbox
file system.
And also, every agent should have a
sandboxed code execution location. So,
it can write files, it can run those
files, and it can do that safely without
exfiltrating anything, without
interacting with an OS at a higher
level. That needs to be baked in as a
primitive to every single
domain-specific agent.
Okay, so, let's say that that's our
ideal agent. And now, let's talk about
that little agent tool there. What is
that? Well, those can be sub-agents,
recursive sub-agents even. You could
have an agent that calls a sub-agent
that calls sub-agents that call
sub-agents. Um, and there could be one
or there could be many of these at
different levels.
So, for example, you could have this
coordinator agent that's at the very
top, and then you could have a
Salesforce agent. And that agent knows
Salesforce inside and out. It knows all
of its APIs, it knows has all the
credentials to communicate with your
Salesforce instance in all the
appropriate ways. And then, it needs to
communicate with a Google Workspace
agent. So, it can do all kinds of stuff
in there. It can run spreadsheets. I can
say, "Hey, what are all my tops uh my my
top sales people this year?" Boom, it
can look in Salesforce, it can
coordinate with the sub agent, create a
sheet for you, send that back.
Perfect.
But, maybe then you need to generate
some assets. So, the Salesforce agent
actually has another sub agent that it
can talk to at any time it wants. And
it's amazing at generating assets. Maybe
that sub agent doesn't just have like,
you know, Codex image generation, maybe
it has Nano Banana, maybe it has an SVG
generator, all kinds of stuff, so that
way it is an amazing asset generator and
performs some of its own reflection and
QA.
And then our primary agent might need a
whole legal team agent just so it can
check the work that's coming out of
these other ones. And maybe the legal
team agent really needs a GDPR
compliance agent just for those European
customers. You know, the main one
doesn't have all, you know, you don't we
don't want to have 45 megabytes of
context just on GDPR. So, we make that a
separate sub agent.
Uh so, you know, may and then maybe the
legal team also needs like an OSHA
compliance agent, which is also very
complicated. And so, it has a separate
one for that. You kind of get the idea.
You can end up with all kinds of highly
efficient, small little agents that are
all working together,
but maintaining small minimal context
windows all the way through.
That's the idea behind domain-specific
agents.
So, thank you very much. I appreciate
you listening to my talk. Again, uh
Standard Agents is where we're working,
standardagents.ai. You can actually sign
up on there uh for an early access.
Um we are slowly starting to roll this
out to a few people. Um if your business
is super ambitious and really wants to
uh try out small domain-specific agents,
then um you know, you can write me
info@standardagents. And of course, I'd
appreciate a follow. Thank you so much.
Bye.